hello everyone good afternoon welcome to
what it's date day too right yes it's
been a long week so yes thank you for
coming my name is Jimmy Bogart you can
find me on twitter @ @j bogart this
presentation will be on my github
I promise I'll push it soon I'm sure
github.com / J Bogart and I blog about
this topic and a lot of other things on
my blog at Jimmy Bogart calm for my day
job I'm actually the chief architect of
a consulting company out of the States
called head spring and so a lot of this
talk is really about some of the
experiences I've had dealing with micro
service communication patterns so a lot
of the clients that I deal with have
some kind of really large existing
legacy system these systems have been
around for sometimes even decades and
they've run the core of the business for
years and years and years but at some
points those systems that are running
the core of the business can no longer
meet the needs of the business they
can't change them easily they can't
deploy them easily and they find that
just progress more or less grinds to a
halt and so they start to look at
alternatives say how can we how can we
move faster how can we better meet the
needs of the business and those existing
systems usually have some kind of bad
name like monolith for example and they
want to move from that monolithic system
to something smaller now there are some
good things about those big systems like
you can just you know call any code you
want to from anywhere in the system and
it all works ok you know if they're
really worried about how entered
different components need to communicate
with each other and when those
organizations move from these very large
single process systems and to lots of
smaller systems and introduces the
problem or the challenge of these
components and services needing to talk
to each other now before we get too far
I didn't wanted to clarify one thing
about I put micro service in the title
because I kind of guarantee as it gets
accepted let's talk let's first talk
like what we mean by a micro service
because that kind of helps set up later
on when we talk about how we think about
these kinds of systems so the original
the original definition for me didn't
work well with any of my clients because
they would say yeah we're doing micro
services I look one level below I'm like
no this is just like a bunch of
API is talking to each other it's not
necessarily what micro services are all
about so I had to think of a definition
that be more appropriate for my
customers and this is the what I came up
with a micro service is still a
service-oriented architecture so all
those like all those things in the early
2000s that everyone went away from there
were some good bits out of there so it's
a service-oriented architecture in which
we try to try to focus the design
towards the smallest still autonomous
boundary and that's autonomy is kind of
the key thing for me in a
service-oriented architecture an
autonomy basically means that this
service can take care of its own
business without having to worry about
other things blowing up and affecting it
so when I'm looking at moving from one
single system to lots of smaller systems
and suddenly I have this problem where
if this one system that way over there
goes down that affects my ability to do
anything then I have to figure out how
do I handle being able to coordinate
these kinds of activities where I can
still stay up and stay alive and be able
to do the job that I was supposed to do
and not worry about that other thing
going down but that's a very different
kind of way building systems from those
single monolithic applications like if
something blows up in a monolith right
just like get an exception you get a
stack trace it tells you exactly where
the failure was if you see a failure in
a distributed system now that stack
trace is actually distributed amongst
many log files amongst all your
different services so if I'm trying to
build a system that's resilient and can
stay up and handle this kind of failures
I have to have a different way of
thinking in a different way of
organizing my systems so what I'm
looking at taking those big applications
and breaking them down to smaller pieces
you have to then ask well what are those
small pieces going to be how do I decide
what's going to be over here versus
what's going to be over there and then
finally how these things how are these
thing is going to communicate with each
other and when I find is there actually
is a lot of parallels between real-world
systems that is like human people based
systems and the kinds of systems that
micro services are good for and if I can
look at a real world system that is
using humans as an analog for micro
services and I see if those kinds of
communications and kind of patterns
would work in the real world that has a
very very high likelihood of success
in the virtual world so in a lot of the
organization's I work with all of our
design exercises are really substituting
these microservices for people and I
like to see it well if people were
trying to do these different jobs how
should they communicate to get things
done so a lot of the problems that we
see in the real world of scaling up
something small and trying to go big are
the exact same kind of problems that we
will see and are in our virtual systems
or micro service based systems so been
looking at a system and I want to scale
it up it gets it's gotten too
complicated too big the same kinds of
solutions I would see there are the same
kind of solutions I would see with micro
service based communication so a good
example of this is looking at human
based systems that have existed for
decades or centuries or even millennia
and these kinds of systems still have
the same kind of scaling problems that
we see in the virtual online world as
well so things like restaurants and mail
order catalogs and those kind of things
that are very people based have this
very similar kind of issue we see with
any kind of online system as well so I
looked at existing human systems and try
to find okay what are what are systems
that I see in the real world that start
very small and then I need to scale up
now I live in Austin Texas for those of
you they don't know that's a very
hipster city it's like the sea of sanity
in a very big ocean of like guns and
stuff being in Texas and so being a
hipster city we have a lot of these
hipster food trucks again something else
we've gentrified and you know made
hipster our food trucks and so in our
office complex we actually have a daily
food truck that comes and then we said
these like kind of clever names the one
I the one I really like the best is this
this hotdog cart
they got like hot dogs that can't be
that interesting except they deep-fry
the hot dogs and then wrap them in bacon
so they're just absolutely like actual
proper like streaky bacon not whatever
you have here like good bacon and so and
so it's absolutely delicious but this
food truck is just run by one single
person so I want to look at that
business model say okay if
I had this very simple process how would
I take that business and try to start to
scale it up so in this bit isn't in this
business it's just one person doing
every single step of the process so when
you want to get that awesome deep-fried
bacon-wrapped hot dog you go up and you
go to the you go to the front counter
you place the order and you don't leave
that spot until you finally receive that
delicious deep-fried hot dog so in this
in this kind of business everything is
done by one single person everything is
synchronous so I'm just standing there
blocking everything until I'm done and
everything is essentially in process so
that kind of system sounds very very
familiar to me because it's a single in
process system where the application
does absolutely everything so this is
almost exactly like our traditional in
tier monolithic architectures where
everything's inside a single process
sure like it's kind of simple because
everything is just in that one system
one application but it comes very
difficult to scale this kind of system
out so those food trucks in the States
are pretty expensive to run like it
costs tens of thousands of dollars for
licenses and all the regulations and
things like that and you have to like
find a good spot to to park in to be
able to make sure that you're able to
make up whatever losses that you have
for the day and so they'll go around and
find like high-traffic areas to make
sure that they can kind of maximize the
amount of revenue they'd see in a single
day so if I'm coming to start one of
these businesses I have to figure out
like well how much should actually
charge for the items I'm going to be
selling to people and I can kind of walk
backwards and say well based on based on
how much my my food costs and kind of
working backwards in there I could
figure like what my per item cost us to
me and then I have to figure out how
much to charge on top of that in order
to make sense for me to be at any given
place so when I'm backing that out I get
money by people ordering stuff and so if
I want to figure out what's the most
amount of money I could make I basically
just look at how long does it take to
process an order and then back out how
many orders would I actually see in a
given amount of time so I can break it
down into individual steps
everything that happens within one
single transaction in this business so
you have the initial taking of the order
and for this it takes like 30 seconds
which still seems like a long time but
this food truck place has like
especially clever names like the hotdogs
the grilled the deep-fried hotdogs with
bacon and kimchi on it it's called a Kim
dog ill oh I know and so you're going up
there you're like you have to like
translate what this clever name means
into an actual food item so that's why
it takes like 30 seconds for you to
actually order and from there there's a
certain amount of time for each
individual step in the process and
finally get to the end you say well if
it takes two and a half minutes to be
able to complete a single order that
means I can just divide that by the
number of minutes an hour and say the
maximum number orders an hour I can have
is that number of orders I can have over
time however if I actually look at the
real statistics behind any one of these
food tricks it never comes close to that
maximum ever and why is that well
there's a few complications here first
of all people don't like to wait in
queues like well in the States we don't
okay I know it's a thing here but we
don't actually like to wait in queues
and so if I see a long line of people
and I'm walking up then I see that long
line and say well I don't want to wait
that long I'm just gonna go find
something else to eat the other thing we
find is we never we never see a constant
rate of flow so even though it takes two
and a half minutes per order we don't
see one person arriving every two and a
half minutes instead we're on our slack
we're saying okay it's time to go get
our hot dogs who wants to come with me
like a group of ten of us go down to go
get our food so we'll see this really
big peaks and valleys and in the number
of people that are waiting in line and I
know if I say it's like two and a half
minutes for order and I see ten people
in front of me I can quickly do the math
to say I'm not gonna be out of here in
the next fifteen minutes or so so
because they're people involved and the
people don't like to wait and these
queues then we see a much lower
throughput than that theoretical maximum
of 24 an hour because again someone
coming in seeing a very long line like
oh well I'm just going to go find
something else to eat
you could say why not us as humans just
alter our behavior when we're going out
to get lunch but no one gets lunch at
12:04 right they have like these
specific times they want to go so we
can't just say well we'll just kind of
go upstream and say people just need to
come in at a more regular pace and you
know I just let you just relax here now
we're going to go down as a group so we
can still like talking whatever and so
at this point this guy's business model
starts to fall down because they see
that I could easily make a profit at 24
an hour or 20 an hour but what I
actually see is much less than that so
what I want to do is maximize the
revenue I can make in the time I'm going
to be there so how can we fix this well
the first thing we could do is scale-up
right well what does it mean to scale up
in this system like buy a bigger food
truck no that's not really thing people
do how about you just like duplicate the
food truck altogether so I had one food
truck now I have a second one with
exactly the same setup but there's a
huge overhead and and being able to get
that food truck license and whatnot so
you don't see like food trucks just get
duplicated all over the place they've
got basically than one but the solution
of course is going to be what everyone
does just hire more workers and each
individual worker is going to specialize
in one aspect of the overall process
here so when I have each person doing
one individual job they can optimize how
they perform that individual step in the
overall process so originally when I
walked up to the counter and ordered
something I would not leave until I had
received my hotdog but in this case we
can start to optimize a process and say
maybe we can actually do several things
in parallel
maybe I don't just do one order our time
can I do multiple orders at a time and
if you see these kinds of systems what
we tend to find then is that the only
queue the visible queue that we can see
going on is the ordering process itself
so if I'm able to do this and now
ordering is the only bottle like my
actual maximum amount of orders I can
take an hour is not that two and a half
a minutes anymore
it's now that just down to that 30
seconds per individual someone trying to
take the order
so my theoretical throughput now can go
up go through the roof instead of 24 per
hour it's not way up to 120 which by the
way it looks great for like if you need
to get a loan or something like look at
how many orders I can take but there's a
problem now how do we actually fulfill
an order in this sort of process I now
have to have these individuals somehow
communicate with each other and us as
people have to figure out what is that
communication need to look like how do I
ensure I'm still able to complete orders
and how do I make sure that the
customers actually happy at the end of
the process so so probably have our 1
the transactions are no longer
synchronous so originally I went up to
the to the to the window I made my
purchase but I as the customer did not
leave that location until I receive my
food in this model though we only stay
at the counter until we've paid and
after that payment has successful we
just go off and mill about over to this
side over there but us and humans in the
real world like does anyone complain
about that like oh no I want my food now
we accept that as a trade-off to say yes
I'm not getting my food immediately but
at least it's getting ordered and
processed quickly well I have to have
these different people in the process
somehow coordinate with this activity of
being able to fulfill this order so how
do later steps know what to do based on
the things that have happened before how
do we know when we're done with an order
and the solution to all of this is going
to be some kind of communication in some
kind of messaging so what I do with my
customers is basically draw these kinds
of whiteboard diagrams where we have
like a box indicating that this is a
micro service kind of cross that out and
I literally will draw a human being to
say pretend this is a person how would
these two services these two people try
to collaborate on some kind of
interaction to be able to get this
overall business transaction complete
and what we'll do is I'll look at every
single interaction in the process to
figure out what's makes the most sense
from an overall business perspective and
from a user perspective for each
individual interaction so the first
interaction is going to be placing that
first
now one of the things I see a lot of
people making the mistake of and moving
from a monolithic architecture to a
microservices based one is they just
want to have some kind of blankets
strategy for how everything should
communicate it's like everything needs
to be rest or or everything needs to be
GRP see where everything must be events
everything must be some kind of
messaging what I find is that no one
individual communication pattern or
solution is going to magically work in
every single scenario and we do have to
actually design and think about every
single situation to understand what
makes the most sense for any given step
of the process so in this first step of
the process what would be the most
logical interaction for a human coming
up and be able to place that order well
first you have to figure out like what
information we need to capture from this
so I from the customer I need to know
what food you want and I need to know
how to notify that customer that their
order is ready because they're milling
about over to the side so from that
initial interaction what is the most
logical sense for that kind of
communication well it's probably going
to be some kind of synchronous
communication you probably wouldn't use
like ASIC messaging I don't go to a lot
of restaurants where you don't directly
talk to the waitstaff you like write
down a piece of paper and slide it over
and then look it on the other side like
that's not usually a thing that kind of
happens so for this one we want to have
that very fast interaction be able to
make sure we complete this order and so
for this one we'll pick some kind of
synchronous communication we also notice
that it's just a person talking back and
forth the customer coming to the window
does that actually write anything down
they just tell the person what they want
and the other person that I decide they
write it down but it's not the customer
that's actually writing anything down so
for this initial order this initial
order process I would choose something
that represents asynchronous non-durable
form of communication and so if I try to
translate well what is it what is the
analog to a verbal communication in the
real world into our online world and for
that one it would be some kind of
probably some kind of rest or RPC
communication so if I look at something
like HTTP HTTP is
synchronous request/response right I
make a request to a server and the
client is sitting there waiting for a
response to come back and say yes I've
received your acknowledgement it's also
not durable so if something goes wrong
with the communication no one's written
it down you may have to you may have to
retry that interaction again and we see
this in the real world as well so if I'm
talking to someone and that paying
attention like you snap your fingers
like hey I'm talking to you and then you
have to repeat yourself and some other
thing in this kind of interaction
initially as well that we're making that
first interaction as a secret is call we
have to be able to handle to make sure
that you know if something gets lost to
communication or that can't communicate
for whatever reason then we'll have to
be able to retry this so our first
initial interaction is going to be just
a HTTP web service call so what patterns
can we see here initially first of all
it's going to be asynchronous request
response I'm going to synchronously call
your service to say I want to place an
order and I'm going to sit there and
wait until I get some kind of response
so that's the easy one right like okay
yes I have a initial interaction
synchronous everything's good now how do
I deal with all these back-end folks
like the people that don't have to like
actually dress nicely to go to work
they're in the back they're messy how do
i how do I deal with all of those folks
do I have durable or non durable
communication between each of these
different folks who is actually going to
manage the overall process of that order
moving to the system and if something
goes wrong how do we manage those
failures
so for each interaction I'll look to see
based on my different patterns available
let's just try one and see if doesn't
make sense so looks like the first one
it is I have to communicate from the
person taking the order to the people
behind the scenes here's the order
information so we could do just a
synchronous request response and you'd
see this in the real world as well so in
that kind of situation you basically add
the order person taking the order and
then they're yelling in the back I got
in order for this and you see that right
sometimes I've been at restaurants where
you're like constant yelling go on
behind the scenes of people barking
different orders from each other and so
it could look something like this right
just say yes I need you to to process
this order and then hopefully they're
listening and return back I got it but
sometimes they're not listening
sometimes they're busy actually making
orders and so it could it be the case
where I say hey I got a new order coming
up and I don't hear any kind of
acknowledgement so I'm like did you hear
me we got an order coming up and so I
may have to retry that again what's
really going on is like they're busy
they're like actually they're performing
the work of the previous order and so if
you're trying to talk to them
synchronously they have to stop where
they're doing turnaround like I got it
okay here's the order I can then go back
to actually doing their work so what
happens if that other side is down okay
like five oh three service unavailable
and then we're in the virtual world we
may just like try to scale that out and
be like we'll just put that in
kubernetes or something and have some
kind of Auto scale whatever they just
you know keep scaling out forever
that still doesn't handle the situation
of something getting timed out or
something not going through successfully
so I could say yes I'm busy I can't do
anything so let's try this again okay
you're not paying attention I'm gonna
tell you to make the order again and
it's like okay I got it
geez I can finally do this however how
do we make sure that's they didn't
actually hear the first time they just
didn't they just never returned a
response in the first place so they
actually did successfully retrieve the
first order information they just didn't
tell me that they got it and I was tired
of wedding so I just moved on with my
life and now if I then tell them there's
another order how do we make sure that
they didn't actually make two of the
same thing so if I if I try to make that
post again and say I need you to
actually place this order and this thing
you tell me I got it but then out the
other side comes two orders and so I
want to make sure that's if I am have
this non-durable form of communication
and I and I'm now introducing the the
possibility that I'm retrying my
communication over and over again then
we need to make sure that's or at least
handle the fact that the receiving side
may
see that may receive that communication
more than one time so there's a word for
this item potency and this is just a
fancy word for saying if you ask me to
do the thing twice I only do it once and
we have to figure out like what makes
sense in order to be able to handle
receiving messages multiple times that
only actually doing the work once so
from this from the actual other side I
need to have some way of knowing was
this the same order as something else or
not it also looks something like it
could be something like a
fire-and-forget sort of message which is
I just tell you the order I just tell
you I need you to process the order but
I'm not going to wait for a response
it's not gonna do it immediately it's
gonna be doing it sometime in the future
so in this case it receives the request
and it's like well I can't do this right
now but I've received it and I'm gonna
do it sometime in the future so it says
yep I got it thanks but I'm not gonna do
it right away I'm gonna do it sometime
in the future at this point we need to
worry about how to flow my orders across
these different places and you can still
see this in real life a picture I have
up here is a burger joint in Austin
Texas called mighty fine and the burgers
are mighty fine
and they're actual paper bag in which
they take the order on contains like
here's the instructions for what to do
and that order written on the bag will
actually flow through the entire system
and on that bag are the instructions of
exactly what to do along each step of
the way so this kind of pattern wise up
front I'm able to determine here all the
steps necessary to be able to process
this order is known as the routing slip
pattern and in this case the initial
person at the very front of the process
looks at the order and writes down the
steps that need to happen as part of
that initial message so in this case I
can look at the order and say right
these are the steps needs to go to the
dress step the grill step the pack step
and I finally give that order to the
customer in a messaging world that's set
of instructions we included on the
message so each individual process along
the way we're
save the message cease that step
performs that step and then forwards
that message to the next step in the
process so there's not like some central
person that's managing the flow as the
pieces go through the steps it's just a
simple straight line through the process
going one step a time until it gets to
the end now there could be some times
where I have extra steps or fewer steps
so in the burger joint if I ordered like
a milkshake well that would be one extra
step in the process that order needs to
go through but that could all be easily
determined all the way up front so each
of these different steps of the process
will have some kind of cue to manage
their own individual set of work and in
real life we can actually see this if
you have a paper-based
restaurant you'll actually see order
tills where they get a a slip of paper
that is the order instructions and they
put it physically on this board with
clips and as orders are completed they
move the orders down in the tool so
they've they've been able to define a
queue for their overall process by
having each of these messages
asynchronous we removed the problem
making sure that everyone is listening
at all times to make sure that
communication drops I have to retry the
message if I go through queues instead I
don't actually have to talk to the dress
person directly I can just put the order
on the table and then at some point in
the future that take that order and put
it up on their board and then finally I
have independence maintained for each of
the steps because each step then can
decide completely internally how they're
going to process each individual step
and the overall order and optimize it
accordingly so the group person be like
well you know what I can actually cook
ten hot dogs at once I have to do one at
a time so if I see a big group people
come in and walk it up let's go again
and drop ten hot dogs down and by the
time we got to the Oder process then all
those hot dogs will be ready
so this is kind of very straightforward
sort of process and we have used this
sort of pattern in our systems where I
have a very linear very deterministic
process but I do find that as I start to
add more and more services this kind of
simplified flow starts to fall down and
so I have to start looking for more more
interesting and more exotic patterns to
be able to handle more complex flows now
a lot of these patterns and I'll be
talking abouts we're actually all
written down in a book called enterprise
integration patterns now that book is
kind of a lousy name it's really just
messaging patterns because it really
like it sets the stages here's how you
get services to integrate with each
other here are three ways that don't
work very well but here's a great weight
a weight that works really well which is
messaging and so a lot of the patterns
we see I'll be talking about are
actually just completely defined already
as part of that system now there was one
part though in the book where he says
okay if you if you go past like just
simple request response simple like
routing slip there's another pattern for
you call the process manager pattern and
this pattern lets you do really complex
stuff and then in the actual text is
like someone should write a book about
all these patterns that exist for
process managers well that book was
published 15 years ago and there's never
been part two yet so unfortunately have
to kind of fill in the gaps of what we
see as those more complex conversation
interaction patterns but I can still
take this very simple system and try to
scale it up in different sorts of ways
and look at what kind of patterns emerge
from those systems to be able to apply
it into the virtual systems that I deal
with so we're going to kick this up to
11 and look at how do larger change how
do larger systems deal with this more
complicated sort of scenarios ends if I
look to in the real world to say well
what larger systems take my food truck
concepts and go global like that's what
fast food is right it's industrial food
production at a massive distributive
scale so if I look at something like
McDonald's which by the way actually
worked at a fast-food joint growing up
so I can actually speak with experience
to how these systems are built
they're much more complex than ours very
simple food trucks an area the food
truck had like one item with different
toppings and that was it so you can have
a very simple set of processes for that
simple scenario but in this case it's
much more complex and they're trying to
get they're really trying to optimize
throughput here so in this case a lot of
the steps are actually independent from
each other you don't have to have a
specific order in which some things
happen but sometimes there are some some
dependencies between individual steps so
in these fast-food joints they have a
specific grill station and they have a
separate station they call the dress
station which is basically putting the
toppings on your sandwich well you have
to finish grilling before you put the
toppings on the burger and so there is
some natural set of dependencies between
those two parts of the system based on
the order are going to be doing
different set of activities so someone
may just come in and order fries and
someone else may come in and order just
burgers and my overall process needed to
be able to handle those different kinds
of orders coming in with the different
kinds of processes so how do we manage
this then our very simple process of
just making the the bag go from one step
to the next won't make a lot of sense
because again what if someone just
orders one item on the other I'm gonna
have a lot of orders coming through one
step in the process that don't make
sense to that's going to cause some it
in efficiencies and efficiencies in this
system so again let's look at each of
these interactions in turn and figure
out what makes the most sense from both
the customer perspective as well as the
overall business perspective to figure
out what is the right interaction model
for each step of the process so the
first one taking an order this is
probably this has changed over the years
because McDonald's does now have like
the kiosks I don't trust those because
like the person behind in front of me
may have had like the coronavirus or
whatever like I don't want to touch that
screen that anyone else is touch I just
want to tell you my order so let's just
pretend we don't have those like you
know giant touchscreens with lots of
germs and we're still just verbally
telling them the order so in this case
it'll be very very similar as our food
truck the initial order
it's still going to be as low overhead
as possible so a verbal communication or
a non durable form of communication and
as part of that interaction I'm still
actually I'm not actually creating your
order at that point in time
I'm just receiving your order and then
it's some kind of back-end process has
actually to take it from there so in
this picture then initials may look very
much the same I'm gonna make some kind
of synchronous request whether it's a
whether it's a Web API or it's an RPC
call the overall idea is that it's gonna
be some kind of synchronous
communication in which after that
response is returned it's not actually
fulfilling the order that point in time
it's just acknowledging yes I've
received your order and go please sit
down
okay so I've received the order now how
do we actually process it I could try
that simple routing slip just have the
order go through all the different steps
that's not very efficient I have lots
more steps going on and so it's gonna
take a long time for that single message
to make it through all this different
steps if I'm gonna have to do one single
step at a time
so synchronous is now synchronous is
also completely untenable here like I'm
not gonna stand there and be like okay
burger person I need to drop the burger
you got to break her down okay okay fry
person I need to drop to the fries now
how many fries three fries oh my god you
know it's like I'm starting to freak out
so trying to do this as some kind of
synchronous operation would be
completely untenable the real world and
doesn't work really well in a virtual
world either routing slip is too
inefficient or routines clip excuse me
too inefficient I'll be going to too
many different steps and if something
goes wrong I can't easily recover from
those failures and so the solution is
going to be some kind of conversation
pattern there's some agreed-upon upfront
way of managing all these different
pieces through a more complex
communication which we would call a
conversation so how does the real world
do this well first of all they're not
using any kind of synchronous
communication to each of one of the
steps that's just that's just not going
to work very well instead what they're
going to do is some kind of broadcast or
publish of this event that has happened
that says
Hey in order to been created what
information do I see in the order it's
just going to be that's just the link
our URL to say and here's all the set of
order details that you can go find so in
this case the person at the register
doesn't really know or care about all
the different subscribers to this set of
information and said they're just
letting the rest of the restaurant know
hey I've got an order that's been
created and that message then gets sent
distinctly to each one of the individual
subscribers now the real world systems
are more complex they can look at the
order and say writes this sort of does
have any fries in it so we're not going
to send that order information over to
the fry because they'll just disregard
it and ignore it something aren't that
sophisticated and we'll just broadcast
out the order to all the interested
parties and then each interested party
then has its own queue to be able to
handle their specific set of ordered
details
now what about completion how do I
figure out when an order is done in this
kind of picture
well how does McDonald's do it the way
McDonald's does is when you go up and
place your order what do they do with
that they then immediately take a tray
and they physically put a tray down on
the table to keep track of the items in
the order so that's what that cashier
does they go on and they put the tray
down and that that physical tray will
hold all the items as the order gets
completed then there's a receipt they
lay down on the tray and that receipt
shows all the items in the individual
order but I still need to figure out how
to coordinate this overall activity so
let's just walk through the process so
this first step completes so that person
takes the completed items and then they
place them on the tray once they place
that item in the tray they look at the
receipt and check the receipt based on
the items that they see on the tray and
if all the items are on that tray then
the order is done but in this case nope
not done because not all of the items
are on the tray second this step in the
process goes
person completes they put the items on
the tray they check the items on the
receipt for the doneness of the overall
order they say no everything's not
completed yet so I'll go back to my
station oh no sirree so finally I get to
the step that does finally complete the
order so this person takes the items
puts them on the tray checks everything
on that receipt for doneness finally
everything is done and now I need to
notify the customer their order is ready
so this pattern is known as choreography
and I I wish things had different names
because I never got get the difference
between these two major patterns because
like no one's dancing here but I guess
that's what we're calling it so in
choreography we have more of an event
based initiation
so something kicks off the overall
process and typically it's in
choreography it's an event that gets
sent out to multiple parties the step
order is not necessarily enforced here
so I don't I don't know exactly what's
step in the process that's going to
complete before others like sometimes
for a given order that fries may
complete first other times the burger
may complete first I don't know but
there's no real dependency between those
two steps so I don't really care which
one finishes first I just need to have
some way to track completion so in a
choreography based conversation
something needs to keep track of like
where I am and the overall set of our
dance here of people coming in and
finishing things so a lot of times I had
to have something to tracks that
completion so that's why that receipt is
on the tray the receipt tracks the
overall completion of this choreography
I call this years ago the observer
pattern because you're observing events
but microservices will call this
choreography so I have to use their word
instead okay that's not enough though
right I finished the order it's done but
now how to actually deliver it to the
customer that is sitting there waiting
for it at their table so I need some way
to correlate orders with people and this
is known as the correlation identifier
pattern that I'm coordinating some
activity
with a final completion step and there
are a few ways we can do this now how
does McDonald's do this I met some of
you still go there right or five guys
whatever
it depends right I have seen some places
that use some kind of natural
correlation identifier so like a
Starbucks or coffee shop they like to be
personal to you like make you feel good
about life because it's hipster and all
that stuff so they use the natural
correlation identifier which would be
your name but that's not always greats
like if you have a common name like
Jimmy well I guess James is more common
then they'll have to do sing as a team
like Jimmy with a cappuccino versus
Jimmy with like the iced mocha
frappuccino half soy half whatever and
so they'll have to like also name out
there so the name can work but there's
gonna be there could be the potential
for collision so we have to make sure
that can still uniquely identify this
process based on that natural
correlation identifier well if that's
that's gonna work for us then we can
choose an artificial correlation
identifier and just make something up
like restaurants for example use an
order number so it's just some
increasing number that goes from like 1
to 99 and when they get to 99 it just
starts to over at 1 again because they
don't have a hundred orders ever going
on at the same time so it really doesn't
matter we're just me to pick one for our
individual process and so depending on
what we're doing we either have to make
something up or we can kind of grab what
we see already going on to say this is
this makes sense for overall correlation
in a fire like an e-commerce situation
they would just generate an order
identifier based on your cart
information let's say this is your order
ID and it's some like gobbledygook thing
that you can you know get your email
whatever then I'm gonna be like hey this
is Jimmy's order and as it goes through
the process like Jimmy's orders ready
you know these big systems don't do that
so this kind of process works really
well except for the fact that it does
introduce the possibility of failures in
our system in this picture in particular
puts a lot of onus on that employee to
be able to correctly check to see if my
orders complete and they always get that
right right you never have anything
missing from your order so what did you
what do you do as someone receiving this
order like the first thing you do is you
open the bag and you check the contents
because something is always missing and
that's because this is a naturally
Messier solution because no one's really
controlling the entire process but it is
a lot more scalable because I'm out
arming a lot more steps to complete in
parallel independent with each other so
this is more like a cookie cutter or
complex system what about other
restaurants that are bigger and more
complex so in a real restaurant like a
sit-down actual restaurant the orders
can be much more complex people can
order all sorts of different things and
make modifications to things and one of
the things is going to be quite a bit
different is the prep time is going to
vary wildly in these kinds of scenarios
so this case timing matters a lot more I
needed to make sure that when I deliver
the food to the end customer that they
don't have like the other steak is cold
where the mashed potatoes are hot I need
to make sure that everything is
completed more or less at the same time
so in this case I need to have a lot
more control over this overall process
and a fast food sort of place like
they're just they're just churning out
fries all the time so it's not
necessarily made to order but in good
restaurants right you know your food is
actually made to order unless you go I
guess some change is still microwave
junk but let's assume you're going to a
good restaurant so who do they have here
to help control this process this guy
where's the sauce there were much more
worse memes for Gordon Ramsay but I
don't have too many curse words here
okay so yeah you have some kind of like
benevolent dictator who is the chef and
they are the one that's actually
controlling this overall process making
sure that your food gets done on time
and it will be delivered out the door so
in this case the chef will receive
incoming orders from the waitstaff and
then based on the theme from the things
they see on that order they will create
a plan for completing that order within
a certain amount of time to make sure
that everything is more or less done at
the same time and it can go out the door
and in order to do so they're going to
be barking orders at people at specific
points in time to say I need this I need
that do this thing do that other thing
so it all starts off with the waitstaff
though and again this is something you
have to actually design like all the way
from the very initial customer
interaction you have to figure out how
those steps should be done so in this
case what we're doing is adding items to
an order that is still a synchronous
communication between the the customer
and the waitstaff so yes I want to add a
burger to my to my order I want to add
some fries and of course a pint of ale
or lager whatever suits your fancy okay
so once the once the waitstaff has
received all this information they wait
for this you know they say is everything
is that all anything else say no we're
good so go ahead and finish the order
and now this poor waste stuff has to go
to like the devil in the back which is
the head chef so they'll let the order
person the chef know yep my order is
done and now you can go on go ahead and
do stuff so at this point the chef is
then going to build out that plan in
their head exactly how they're going to
coordinate all these activities based on
the expected completion time and cook
time of everything going on they also
have to balance like okay this this
specific station may be backed up so I
may have to wait a little bit longer but
they're the ones that are really kind of
controlling that entire process by the
way I've never actually worked in a
restaurant I just like watch a lot of it
on TV and this seems to be how things
actually go behind the scenes how much
what right right it's you a few times
like that
kind of no no so so this head chef is no
longer using events because he doesn't
trust the individual sous chefs or
whatever they're other people behind the
scenes to be able to make those
decisions about what should be may win
so they're X gonna be using more of a
request response planner to say hey I
need you to make this thing hey I need
you to do this thing
oh I've reached tubers I received a
response that the thing is complete now
I'm gonna send that command to go ahead
and deliver that item to the customer
because we want our beer first right yes
now I receive a message that says I want
to send a message out to the fryer
saying okay now burgers take a little
bit longer to cook or steak or whatever
so I'm gonna wait a little bit and then
when it when I feel it's ready then also
that message out to the other person to
say go ahead and start this next step in
the process now as things completes
they're replying back to the originator
saying I am now completed this item and
I've now completed this item and the
chef keeping track of everything
themselves once all the items are
complete for that order finally they can
again bark out the order to the weight
stop to say ready right now it's time to
actually deliver this order to the end
customer so this pattern in which I have
this benevolent dictator in the middle
who is directing all the work that needs
to happen using request response or
commands and replies this is known as
orchestration again I think the the
people come here with these names like
like musing and dancing so we have
choreography and orchestration so the
idea is that you have some conductor
that's telling the entire orchestra what
to do in this case I had that head chef
that is directing all the different
items that need to happen so in this
case instead of this process starting by
like a set of events coming in instead
this processes started out by some
individual message and then from there
and out we're using request response or
commands and replies to coordinate all
the other services telling them exactly
what to do the response is coming back
typically indicate the completion or the
result of that operation
or comes back and says the sauce is
burned I need you to retry the sauce or
let's just put it out the door anyway
but it's really that the person in the
middle that's making all the decisions
about exactly what to do based on these
replies of these different steps
completing so in this case there's a lot
less tracking of individual status
because the person in the middle is the
one that's really doing all the
coordinating of all the different work
so they'll know in their head why won't
starts this step until that other step
completes so I don't have to keep track
of what is done when because they're
they basically got the workflow in their
head of how things need to operate based
on the individual replies coming back so
these are kind of two competing sort of
patterns where I have one that's more
command based in orchestration and one
that is more of it based in choreography
and again this is one of those things
that like people new to micro services
want to like put some line in the sand
saying we are only doing choreography
because events are good right so let's
do choreography and other folks like now
we want a complete control over the
system so always do orchestration but
again in the real world we see that
those kinds of patterns make sense in
some scenarios but don't make sense in
others so we still have to analyze the
overall business goals and interactions
we want to have to determine which one
of these things that make will make more
sense for our overall situation so we do
this by looking at the process flow and
looking at the coupling between
individual steps does this step depend
on that step or can it be done
completely independent of each other so
what we usually see come out of this
then is choreography is something we
usually do inside a service boundary
wait a minute I have got these backwards
this is why I hate these names
orchestration choreography it's usually
actually orchestration inside of a
service boundary well just cross that
out
orchestration usually inside of a
service boundary and choreography
usually between service boundaries and
the reason why we have this is because
if I have a set of services who only
communicate with commands then it's
gonna feel like that like did the jerk
chef who's like barking at everybody all
these different orders and there's no
autonomy I can't just do what I
need to do outside of you yelling at me
and so you see a lot of those
interactions the very command oriented
or RPC oriented so that introduces
process coupling and sometimes even
temporal coupling in which that person
is yelling at you and you have to be
paying attention otherwise I'll get even
more mad at you so if I want to avoid
process coupling and temporal coupling
that's why we you'd usually see
choreography is something you have
between services now if I'm inside my
service boundary then I can do whatever
I want because it's my business how I
get my stuff done so inside of my own
service boundary that's why you see
typically more command oriented sort of
conversation patterns so I wanted to
finish up looking at the repart of this
whole enterprise that is I'm up into
this point we've really been talking
about how to how to fulfill an overall
business process there's an important
piece here in that in our systems that
we build and the real work like are our
actual you know computer systems we have
to worry about these systems being able
to handle the read side of things
separate from the kind of business
transaction backend parts so if I look
at the real world what is a similar kind
of scenario that they would see this is
very similar to menus the menu do you
see when you walk into a store is that
very cheap read side of the system and
reading that menu is very cheap right it
only costs like whatever the light
energy cost is to take that light and
bounce it off the menu into your eyes
that's the cost it would be to read that
menu the other thing we see is that menu
is built directly for the customers
involved everything on there is designed
for you to buy stuff and pay the money
and get an order it's not it's it's
completely kind of cut off from however
the backend was actually used to build
that out it's 100 percent we're
designing this exactly for what the
customer needs and one thing we're not
doing is trying to not we don't want to
expose the decisions and business logic
of how that menu is created to the
end-user where ideally we were just
building that menu and that read version
of our world
to be able to accomplish that business
goal of like getting the customer to buy
stuff now in the real world how would
the how would the business owner create
the menu well it's not easy like you
have to figure out where you're gonna
get this different food if you have some
exotic menu item then you have to figure
out well how is that going to impact the
overall bottom line how do I charge for
it do I charge the same thing for every
single place in the world or even at one
given region so those back-end systems
are optimized for managing the menu they
have all the decisions and business
rules about how to add new items and
change prices and things like that and
it may be do more complex analytics like
looking at the future saying well I know
pork prices are going up or down which
is why you see the nikah rib sometimes
by the way and the states like pork
features go down and so they buy a bunch
of pork and then McRib is back but
that's all built in these backend
systems that they're not exposed to the
end-user all you see is the end user is
billboard that says McRib is back and
you go eat that nasty pork so yeah all
these kinds of things you see built the
Meccans but in the system's ice I
usually see for my customer these big
monolithic systems they try to solve
both problems with the exact same
solution that is I got some front-end
system and some back-end system that are
both talking to the exact same database
and with larger and larger systems we
very often find that that same system in
the database that is used to build the
back-end management is not remotely
appropriate for the front-end systems as
well so good that's equivalent in the
real world of like and instead of me
walking up and seeing a menu I see like
a spreadsheet with like a tab open like
okay this is the prices for today like
you never see that right you don't
actually see the backend system from the
will or perspective you see this nice
pretty stylized menu that is there to
help you make your decisions so it's
very difficult to try to solve these two
different very different problems with
the exact same model they have two very
very different characteristics in the
use cases and the read scenario of
course I can actually pulling data from
a lot of different sources to be able to
show to the end-user and so I'd really
want two different solutions for this
heavy read model versus this heavy right
so yeah let's just like chainsaw the
database in half right if only it were
that easy because we still have to
figure out how to get these databases to
talk to each other so we can use
something like link servers right that's
always to connect new no don't do that
SSIS packages new boo yeah so we have to
figure out how these difference how that
back-end system can communicate changes
to the front-end system so if I look at
the real world as well I want to see how
these different pieces are going to
interact with each other we find that
very often is that updating to the menu
in the Roo world is more on a scheduled
basis so it's not real-time that is so
if someone if a business person makes a
decision on a price it's not like as
soon as that like that lever clicks in
their brain that a new price shows up on
the menu because one that's not a very
good experience to the end user like
going to a restaurant and seeing the
price change while you're at the
restaurant is like I would leave right I
just like I wouldn't I wouldn't I
wouldn't shop I wouldn't I wouldn't be
there anymore
so it's more of a scheduled basis like
typically it's it's like nightly or
whatever like when when the shop is
closed then we'll go ahead and update
the prices if you want to but again it's
something that the business decides how
often and exactly when those new prices
go out the door the other thing I see is
that menu is immutable that is it can't
have like the weight are being like ooh
that's too high of a price scratch it
out this is a better price no I was like
even though the data is now moved out to
these menus and it's physically
duplicated right it's not like the
person reading them in you can be like
no I don't like that price I'm gonna
have something else no I'm gonna guess
would be nice but you know never
actually see that so even though the
data is duplicated right physically
duplicated in the real world no one no
one screams like cry cries murder right
even though I have prices printed on
dozens of menus I it's not like there's
some DBA in the background like wait a
minute
that's duplicate data oh my god let's
get that back into one system again like
the real world is able to deal with this
messy
of duplicate data so how come our
systems can't as well so in this case
when I want prices to updates then we
can use a similar kind of interaction we
model we saw earlier which is to publish
outs notification saying hey price has
changed from A to B so I need everyone
to go then update their menus and if I
have more than one store or more than
one restaurant then each of those gets
that like daily email whatever of here
are the new prices for today so in this
case the publisher one will keep track
of who all the subscribers are so knows
who to send out these different order
different menu information - it's going
to have a durable format as well right
I'm not just gonna yell out to my
different stores price changed or just
like calm on the cell phone I probably
send it at some sort of durable format
so that that they don't lose those
pricing updates this will create an
individual message per subscriber so
that if something goes wrong in
processing those menu updates it doesn't
affect any of the other stores
so if store C closed or their mail is
not delivered today for whatever reason
or they didn't or they'll have their
email whatever the other stores can
still successfully receive and process
that message so we've got a durable
messages to each of our subscribers each
of our subscribers is unaware of each
other so there's no coupling between all
the different stores they can process
that message independent each other and
again if one stores closed then the
other menus can still be continued to be
updated so in this picture when I have a
pricing change that knees go out is
business going to stop if that store
doesn't process that message right away
this is usually the argument I have to
get into with when I'm talking about
splitting up I read heavy database from
that transactional right system in the
backend it is like well then it's gonna
be out of date right it's it's it's
stale data and stale data is that like
the devil right but in the real world we
have stale data all the time we in the
real world are just able to handle that
by saying well and the case where these
things don't quite match up then we may
have to have some other kind of business
process to handle that actual messiness
so in this real world if store a B and C
don't have exactly the same price
at all times does anyone care like am i
go I might physically driving to each of
these stores to check to see if the
prices are exactly the same probably not
it would be weird though if I see like a
different price online Bish's vs.
physically in store but it's not
something that me as a customer it
really needs to know about or be aware
of that these different stores may not
have exactly the same price on any given
day so if it doesn't affect the end user
and it's not severely affecting our
bottom line
then we in the real world accept this
kind of messiness and just kind of move
on with their lives
so some parting thoughts here the
constraints of the rural world haven't
changed that just that the latency is
much shorter but latency is still not
zero not everything is entirely
instantaneous even though we may use
like G RPC and all this stuff where
latency is very short it's still not
zero so we still have the possibility
where things get blocked and delayed the
solutions for the world world can be
applied directly to a distributed world
because the same kind of principles we
want to run independent systems and
people in the real world are the same
kinds of principles we want to apply to
our virtual world as well so us as
humans like to have autonomy at agency
we like to be able to do our own thing
without being told what to do all the
time and so our services are better
designed with those kinds of
characteristics in mind as well
so the real world solved these
distribution problems with messaging and
conversations and coordination so if we
just apply those same kinds of solutions
that the room world has already figured
out to our world
then our systems can be healthy and be
successful as well
so thank you very much that was
effective microservice communication and
conversation patterns if you have
questions I'll be here afterwards
otherwise have a great rest of the
conference thank you
[Applause]